hi everyone my name is Tamra chambers
and this is Tamra's never seen and today
I'm watching The Last Starfighter this
one has been on my list for so it's also
one that I had never heard of until
starting Tamra's never seen I guess it's
like a an 80s kid sci-fi class I have a
Star Trek dress on I've got some space
buns I'm feeling the space vibe I needed
one more movie before
Tamm tober fest time Tobar fest starts
next week and I thought this would be a
nice refreshing film hopefully knock on
wood
dear lord please after Freddy got
fingered don't sit down I have to do
this now okay are you ready let's do it
[Music]
solid it was super solid I had a really
good time watching that it's super
brought me back to the crappy sci-fi
that I watched as a kid believe it or
not I did actually see things as a child
mostly terrible sci-fi I grew up with
Star Wars and Star Trek and the sci-fi
channel before they changed the logo
under the old logo those were the days
remember when Doug didn't have a white
wall hand cream wall those were the days
I thought the effects were garbage but
also kind of impressive because this is
you know a sci-fi film in the 80s and
there was a lot of special effects being
thrown about and they were not good but
I don't know were they good for the time
that's something that I just I when I
was watching I was like whoa yikes
terrible and then I realized like I
don't know maybe not maybe they were
good for the time you know I did think
there were some pacing problems for sure
there were amazing moments on earth and
in the trailer park and then everything
in space was like double the amount of
time I should have been we have like six
scenes where our main character Alex is
trying to decide if he wants to be the
Last Starfighter or not and you know
their longest scenes we don't need all
of that time I also really love that
it's set in a trailer park it's really
easy to put yourself there it's more
down-to-earth more relatable I don't
know you see movies like home alone
where they're in a huge mansion and it's
cool and like you want to put yourself
there but this is like oh yeah cool way
more relatable I think so he breaks the
last starfighter record and he's very
excited he goes and he excitedly tells
his mom that he's broken it and then she
excitedly tells him that he didn't get
the loan that he needed for college so
he gets to go to Community College
really sad now Community College
Community College is a great option but
he really had his heart set on something
else and that is like a hard thing to
watch so he's walking around
for sad just got a huge gut punch of
college and somebody shows up in a back
to the future s car named Centauri and
beta and they take him up into the stars
and explained that he is now a
Starfighter and the effects are terrible
right like right the effects are bad but
it's so fun he gets to be this star
fighter because he's been recruited by
this arcade game and if that were the
case if that's how that worked I would
have long ago been turned into a Kirby
but the blue one and then put to battle
out and Super Smash Brothers and 64 he's
just bragging that I'm really good at
that game they show his room back on
earth back in the trailer park and
there's something under his covers
pretending to be him she's like kind of
groggy and making groaning noises
pretending like maybe he's sick or sad
about the college thing everyone leaves
him alone but then the thing that's
pretending to be him pulls the blanket
up and it's this hideous slimy humanoid
kind of thing but it's like it's
apparently like it's obviously the
growing into like a copy of Alex but
it's not quite there yet it's disgusting
and awesome the practical effects
delighted me to my core even if they
weren't like amazing I don't know it's
just so much more fun to watch practical
effects I think I wrote the bad guy
literally melts a good guy spies head
off with a laser which is amazing it's a
it's a maser no no I tried man I feel I
wrote the bad guys the best even though
he's like not in it that much he's kind
of setup is this like crazy bad dude and
then you see him like maybe four times
throughout the film he's like pretty
easily defeated the alien hair is great
all of the aliens have like old man hair
like with nothing on the top even even
the female aliens I love it at this
point alex is a bit overwhelmed and he's
like no I can't be a Starfighter I'm
just a kid and so he goes back to earth
and you find out that the weird flesh
monster that was under his covers was
beta who was turning into
so now there's two Alexes there's also
an alien in the trailer park now because
the evil of the bad guy has reached
earth and so then alex is like well i
guess i will be a Starfighter now
because I have to save my friends and my
family but all the action with the alien
in the trailer park centauri gets shot
and he's like no I'm fine then he
immediately dies it's a bummer so a lot
happens but not really anything happens
all the star fighters died in an
explosion you know of course
so he's The Last Starfighter but there
is a great like dialog between him and
Greg's Greg's Greg Greg Greg is his like
second-in-command he's awesome he has a
hilarious little laugh and he's cute and
I want him to be my friend Alex goes you
mean they're all dead and Greg says
death is a primitive concept I prefer
thinking of them as battling evil in
another dimension yeah for sure I want
that on my tombstone then after it's
revealed that he's the last star
fighters I get too much I don't want to
be The Last Starfighter no no there's
like a six minute scene of him and Greg
in this ship and they're talking about
their families and what supports them
and strategies and then he's like well
you know what maybe I am The Last
Starfighter by Mohammed and they destroy
all evil it's like it was well that was
pretty easy that wrapped up pretty quick
pretty quick the giant space battle
happens it's not very engaging again the
effects really didn't do it for me
it's kind of like going back to an older
video game console though it's like now
I can't go back to older games where I
can't control the camera as well it just
it really messes me up and I feel like
maybe it's a similar thing going back to
really old old special effects I
appreciate them but kind of it's kind of
hard for me to deal with them personally
why why I'm complain complain
Alex returns to the trailer park
everyone's stoked mags is so happy and
they kiss it's it's a really good scene
I cried I'm such a SAP I literally cried
at the last starfighter
because Maggie went with him and she
didn't want to leave it this small town
she was from yes
girl I feel you you know what I would
love I can't believe I'm about to say
this because I don't feel this way about
like any movie ever I would really love
to see it be remade now with effects now
and like a better budget and still using
practicals and I would love that so much
I bet you'll be wondering how to get
your own beta Tamara to review media
content yeah just beta edit everything
please help surprisingly the earth parts
are more entertaining than the space
part yes yes that is surprising and also
very true I'm hoping that even if you
don't like the film you can at least
have an appreciation but it is one of
the first films to use CGI is that true
okay well if that's true that's very
impressive and I did really enjoy the
film you will be amazed at some of the
earliest CGI committed to film you will
cringe at the crap practical effects oh
my gosh so I wasn't amazed though I do
appreciate that it was one of the first
that's a big thing
I love the practicals you will love it
it is cheesy and dated but damn does it
have heart for days that's really the
thing right that's what you want in a
film like even if it's cheesy even if it
has crappy CGI even if it has terrible
practicals and a bad script like a you
you need it just to have that heart to
pull you through and to get you through
the film and it totally did it was
really really fun Tamara Seal of
Approval I should have one of those made
someone make me that now put it in and
then a seal of not approval next week I
am starting tempo borefest throughout
all of October I have some really fun
ones planned I think I'm doing Monster
Squad and I forget thank you so much for
watching and I will see you all next
week
[Music]
[Applause]
you